Bill's in Richmond Virginia hi Bill how
are you hey wife and I we're we're in
baby step number two
okay we $97,000 on a line of credit and
we just had one of those pickups in life
where my car is now missing new data
transmission in your old car probably
worth $2,000 it's gonna cost more to put
the transmission and it's worth it worth
so right now what my question is I've
looked at other cars and I saw one that
I like last night about $5,500 agreed on
a price should I borrow all my line of
credit to get that car cuz then when
they need to go back and forth to work
yeah that's my question please
so you have a thousand dollars saved and
what's your household income about 165
to 190
oh wow great income okay and you have
two cars or one two cars one now got a
transmission problem alright alright I
got that okay but your wife has a car
right yeah okay and she work outside the
home yeah okay
and I mean here's the thing certainly
the world is not gonna come to an end
and stop spinning on its axis if you go
borrow five grand making 165 thousand on
your way out of debt right but there's
something that happens in the psychology
and the emotions of what we're trying to
do that's that that that's kind of
fallen off the wagon and so i if I'm in
your shoes I'm gonna force some
unbelievable discomfort for a very short
period of time to make the point to
myself that I'm done with that and so
it's what Sharon and I have done many
many times in our lives in other words
what we said is we don't borrow money
now how do we solve this problem you see
what I'm saying and if you draw that
line in the sand and you chisel that in
stone then how do we solve this problem
well you make really really good money
and so you could have if you stop
everything you could have $2,000 $3,000
next month right and yeah so I mean so I
don't know you you pair up in one car
for a month you rent a car from you know
from from dollar for a month I don't
know which would be I don't know 300
bucks or something right you got that
and but if you just said I don't have
the option of borrowing money because I
don't borrow money then how would I
solve this problem I want to skin this
cat right and that's what that's what's
been so freeing to Sharon and I for so
many years because we've run into stuff
like you're running into of there's
there's a lot of stuff we wanted to do
and couldn't do right then or it was
really uncomfortable or whatever
especially in the early days of doing
this stuff which is what you're in so
you can certainly do whatever you want
to do I'm gonna advise you to take some
kind of an uncomfortable inconvenient
methodology that caught because I don't
see anything convenient or comfortable
that's gonna allow you to have a car
tomorrow and so you know the two things
that come to mind is pair up in one car
or rent a car for a month or if you got
a you know as your your grandmother got
a car that's sitting in our driveway 90%
of the time you borrow it for for three
weeks I mean with the kind of money you
guys make in one or two checks you could
have three or four thousand dollars if
you stopped everything so stop your debt
snowball stop everything and we're gonna
go solve this emergency problem we've
got oh by the way your car sells without
a transmission in it for five or six
hundred bucks you're gonna get some kind
of money out of it salvaged and that
goes in the territory it's certainly an
emergency you can use the thousand
that's laying there and then we start
again and we you know baby step 1 is
$1,000 saved and then we
back on the dead snowball that's what I
gotta advise you to do because
something's gonna happen inside of your
all's relationship inside of your
behavior and because you said we don't
do this anymore and that's what I'm
worried about you to do and that's my
reasoning because folks everybody out
there listening here's the thing we
solve so many of our problems that we
have with that that it just becomes
normal and everybody's in that
consequently everybody's broke so we
somehow have to there has to be
something that snaps down inside of you
now Sharon I didn't have a choice we
went broke you guys listening you got a
choice
I mean Bill's got a choice he can go
either way and nobody's gonna call you
stupid or crazy or whatever but you know
you got you could go either way you
could you can go get the fifty five
hundred dollars and then just turn
around pay it right back off you can you
you'll be okay to do that it's not the
end of the world but there's something
to be there's something that you acquire
in your character that you acquire in
your spirit when you say I don't do that
anymore
I don't do that anymore and there's not
a circumstance under which I do it and
then we figure it out and you know
that's what you're facing and I've had
lots of stuff I didn't do over the last
thirty years since I quit borrowing
money because I didn't have the money
what's the stuff there's always
something hey that's my opinion so it's
just fun to think about because it's a
spiritual philosophical discussion more
really than its a math discussion for
you bill good good call man and I
appreciate your spirit on this